Well, hey, everybody. Welcome
to the data science hangout.
If this is your first
time joining us today, Hello.
It's so nice to meet
you. I'm Rachel.
I lead customer
marketing at Posit.
If this is your first
data science hang out.
Say hi in the chat too,
because we all wanna
welcome you in here,
especially anybody joining
for the first time.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across all
different industries.
We're here every Thursday at
the same time, same place. So
if you are watching on
YouTube later sometime in the future
and you wanna join us five,
you can use the link below
to add it to your calendar.
At the hangouts,
we're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming environment for everybody.
Love to hear from everyone
no matter your years of
experience, your titles, your languages
you work in, or industry.
And it's totally okay if
you just wanna listen in here.
Maybe this is your lunch break
or you're out for a walk or
something. But if you wanna
jump in and add some context to
something or ask questions, you
can raise your hand on zoom,
and I'll keep an eye out.
You could put questions
in the Zoom chat,
and feel free to just put a
little star next to it if it's
something you want me to
read out loud instead.
And then lastly, we also
have a slide link where you
can ask questions anonymously,
which I realized I forgot to
create. So I will create that
in one of the first questions,
and then we'll share it
in the the chat here.
But with that, I am so
excited to introduce my two cohosts for
today, Joseph Powers, principal
data scientists at Intuit and
Jen Wing, formerly VP of
product and growth at ThreadUp.
And I I thought today was
a really fun example of how
community and data
friends happen.
I met Joe at the
Posit Conference,
recently,
and we had a bit of an
impromptu pizza party with
Javier and Seth from the
hangouts here too. And then
Joe, I'll introduce me
to Jen here as well.
So I'd love to have you
both introduced yourself and share a
little bit about
your background?
Also something like to
do outside of work too.
Jan, you should
be dark. Oh, no.
Okay. So I'm Jen Wang. I,
yeah, was that threat up,
which is an online marketplace
for secondhand clothing for five years.
And before that, had done a
PhD in kind of behavioral science,
looking at you know,
environmental decision making.
Joe and I met during grad
school actually taking a bunch of classes,
but one of them being a
really the the data science class that
probably turned us both
into data scientists.
And so I'm really
excited to be here and,
I have spent a lot of time
thinking about career and and
all these things is something
that Joan and I have talked
about over the last
many, many years.
And then outside of work, I mean,
I love to do a lot of
things, but most recently
I've been cooking a lot a lot.
So I'll just mention that.
Yeah. I,
had several careers
previous to this one.
Was initially over the
furniture maker, for seven
years. And,
I started teaching woodworking
and and became interested in,
like, questions
around, like, students'
motivation and
how people, like,
perception of their environment
can, like, improve their
their learning outcomes.
And so that led to, yeah,
getting a PhD in educational
psychology and had to learn
programming and statistics
along the way. And,
these data science jobs emerged
in Silicon Valley around the
same time. So
that was, that's that
that brought me here.
Outside of work, I I still
enjoy furniture making.
I'm just grateful not to have rely
on it for my primary income anymore.
So, yeah.
I see some love for
your hobbies in the chat here.
Javier, I thought you had a
a quick follow-up question for Jen.
Oh, yes. Have you ever
asked what I enjoy cooking?
And I was thinking about it as
my mistake is I often buy buy
veggies from Costco, so then
I have to figure out, like,
many recipes for
the same ingredient.
Awesome. Well, let's
we'll jump in here.
I get to ask some
of the questions in the beginning
while we wait for questions
to come in from everybody.
But at the hangouts, we
do often talk a bit about,
hiring, but it's more
often from the employer.
Side, but thinking more
from the the candidate side,
I know somebody had reached out to
to me about that last week too.
I know you both have some
experience transitioning from
academia to industry,
and would love to just learn
a little bit from you about maybe
some tips you might have for us
or people who are in a similar position.
So I'll let you go first.
Yeah. I,
collecting on my own, path,
and then I I also still
speak with a lot of people,
regularly, we're
transitioning. And
I'll try to offer the advice
that I wish I had, you know,
six years ago,
which is that, like,
If you're coming out of
an academic background,
it's easy to feel like
you're you're not qualified or you're
unprepared or, tech careers,
you know, in an industry.
And that's really, really
far from the truth.
You're actually you have an
incredibly unique and valued skill set,
the challenge is learning how to
talk about it in ways that a
non academic is
gonna recognize.
And I hope that's something
you get out of the state.
And so and and this
doesn't just apply to academics. You
know, if you had a career
previously in, like,
nonprofit work or government
work and you know you're
thinking about transitioning to I think
a lot of this is gonna
apply for you too. And so
what are the big things? Like,
I think it would be easy
to miss, your soft skills.
I don't use that soft
term dismissively at all.
They are the most
valuable skills.
And these are things like
the ability to take a vaguely
scoped problem and turn it
into an act line of research.
If you finished a PhD,
you know how to do that.
Other factors,
like your ability to translate
your expertise to to people who
are intelligent, but don't
share your particular expertise.
That is a huge,
skill set. You know,
in order for you to
have influence within your organization,
you're gonna need to translate
your expertise to leaders and
other stakeholders
who, you know,
don't have your
particular background.
And you got a lot of
practice in public presentation and translation,
during your academic experience
that most people never get.
I was never formally trained
in public presentation
until I got into my PhD
program. And then just out of,
like, self
preservation, you know,
your lab members to
protect the, and, you know,
reputation and
integrity of the lab,
they're gonna give you a lot of
guided feedback on how to present, well.
So it's it's easy to get
hung up on, like, oh,
I I don't know how
to do this particular modeling technique
in Python, and it's, like,
Those are the hard skills
in the sense of, like, soft
skills, but you can
learn those pretty quick.
You're bringing in a lot of
soft skills that that are very,
very rare. They're so rare.
They're not gonna be in the
job posting a lot of times.
You're gonna need
to proactively plug them
throughout your resume,
throughout the interview
process. And I promise you
you will see the hiring managers
perk up when they start
hearing about these really rare
abilities, that you've had the
last five, six years to develop.
Yeah. And I I guess to to
add on to that, I think, one,
there are two things that kind of
come to mind for me here is
that one is that, expertise
is truly relative. Right?
Anybody who works in industry
knows this. You easily are the
expert on wise thing in
your organization because as long as
you provide as long as you
know more about that than anybody
else in your organization,
you are the resident expert.
And I think that, when
I was transitioning,
that was one thing that
I worried about is, oh,
I don't know enough.
But I was just talking to
somebody yesterday and I was
telling her, like,
You already know way more about
this industry than anybody I've ever hired.
And ten out of ten times,
I would rather take somebody
who knows a little bit less
about the industry but has
a proven track record of being
able to learn very quickly
and can pick it up. Right?
So I think that's something
that anybody who's in this room
is clearly interested in
learning and is curious and
wants to improve their skills. So
I have no doubt about that.
That's kind of the first
thing of, like, expertise is relative.
And then the second one
is kind of, you know,
what Joe was saying is
you're trying to translate your skills
into something that your
audience and people who are
hiring can understand One of the best
pieces of advice I got was from,
David Kelly who kind of
established the design thinking
method and and the d
school at Stanford,
And he really talked
about how, you know,
every industry and
every organization
is really just a group
of people who get together and
kind of decide what
the standards are. Right?
And you all know
this in data science.
The standards in data science
have been evolving and shifting
and what's really
high quality and,
a cutting edge
has changed a lot.
And so in order to
actually understand how to translate
your skills into
what's most valuable,
I personally think one of the only
ways that you can do it is
you have to talk to people and
you have to talk to a lot of
people to understand how they,
what, like,
even the specific words that
they use to describe certain
skills can be sort of signals
to them that you know or
understand how
things will work.
And so I remember going
to David Kelly and saying like,
oh, I'm debating between
these two jobs right now.
One is, like position a and the
other one is position b. Do you
think if I take position b,
it'll make it hard for me to
do position a stuff later on?
And he was like, John, like,
I'm not an expert in this
field, but it's knowable.
And if you don't
understand the answer yet,
it's because you haven't talked
to enough people in the field.
You need to talk to
enough people to, like,
wrap your arms around
the norms of that group,
and then you'll
know the answer.
I think the takeaway
there for me is, like,
you need to talk to people
to understand what they value and
and how the community works,
but also that it's knowable.
I think a lot of people assume
that You can't get that kind of
understanding until you've been
working in that industry for
multiple years, and certainly
your understanding will,
you know, you'll get a lot
more once you work in it.
But if you talk to a
lot of people, you can get, like,
eighty, ninety percent of the way
there for a job decision, I think.
I wanna jump on top of
that one because it's really it's really
good about talking to people.
LinkedIn is an incredible tool
for making the transition.
And maybe, like, I don't know
a lot of people in industry yet.
I didn't, you know, I didn't
either at one point. And, actually,
you'll find that cold calling on
LinkedIn can be very, very effective.
I typically looked for
people who had, like,
a PhD in their name,
or who I could see
had some academic background or some
background similar to mine. And
then just reach out and say,
like, Look, I I'm trying
to make the transition.
Could you spare fifteen
minutes to talk to me?
These can be very
vulnerable conversations.
You're not trying to
impress them right now.
You're trying is
devastating to get, like,
a lay of the land and to
scope, like, how your skills might fit in.
And overwhelmingly,
those people actually turn
into your backers. Like,
they'll submit your
resume internally.
Really, just after an
hour meeting. Like,
they'll see that you're
like a thoughtful resourceful person,
and, you know,
you're a safe bet.
But to Jen's point, like,
you learn the lay of the land
so that you you're better
prepared to talk about your
skills and and what
you have to offer.
And and also to know
for where you fit in.
Absolutely.
I see, Sita, you had a question
in the chat a bit earlier.
Do you wanna jump in?
Sure. My camera always asks
me. Oh, there we go. Hey.
So I was really intrigued
by the conversation about
transitioning from
academia to industry.
And I would really like
to understand because,
hopefully that's a direction I
would wanna pursue because I am
PO biologist trying to
transition into data science,
and I work at the data
science lab now at the heart,
and trying to really trying
to understand where I go from
knowing all this intense
biology knowledge,
which is purely bench skills
and now moving into more
genomics and technology
driven and using
you know,
these newer technologies to
really understand and answer
genomics questions. But for me,
what has been
interesting in this even
medium shift from being in the
lab to being in a data science
lab where people are
focusing on building more reproducible
workflows, etcetera.
One thing that I feel like
there's a stop gap is when I
was a postdoc, I was like
leading my project. I was in charge.
I was determining the scope
and the future of that project.
And here I'm just,
a part of something which
is also really exciting,
but then you feel like a sense
of less control in a way,
and more directed.
And I kinda wanted to see
what you guys thought of that. Thanks.
My experience has been that,
like, the job levels
within data science,
are very tied to how much
direction versus self direction
you're gonna engage in.
So when you come in as like
a base level data scientist or analyst,
your work is very highly
scoped for you. It tends to be
like execute this solution
to to oversimplify it.
You move up a level, and
now you're being asked,
you know, find a solution to
this problem that I'm giving you.
You move up below
another level of staff,
and now you're being asked,
choose which problems
are worth solving.
And and so, like,
as you move up,
your scope and the amount
of autonomy and responsibility you
have for for for
directing your work.
It keeps increasing.
But yeah, I would say,
like, you know, your experiences,
yeah, as you get started, your
work tends to be more scoped.
But then as you demonstrate
that you can choose good
solutions and choose
problems solving,
you tend to be given more and
more autonomy and then, you know, the,
responsibility and
promotions go with that.
Yeah.
I think I I think the other
thing that kind of your
question by the way,
I'm loving this chat.
There's so much like
good sharing from everybody.
But one of the other things
that I was thinking about too
is that, essentially, right, with
any job and any organization,
there are trade off And so I
think one of the big trade offs
with academia in theory, at
least, is that with academia,
you're supposed to get, like,
full intellectual freedom,
although hard to get until you
get tenure, but you know, in theory,
you get full academic freedom and
you can kind of pursue and
set a lot of your,
your own schedule and and your
work And the reason I think you
can do that is that you're a
lab or where you work kind of,
the act autonomous Right?
They're in their own line
of research, etcetera.
When you go into a company,
especially the bigger
the company gets,
there are just
more interdependent right?
You're trying to work on
things that affect and and interact
with more people,
but the trade off for that
is that oftentimes the impact on
the reach is also
very different. Right?
So in academia, you're kind
of in your little little area,
and you wanna make an
impact. Oftentimes,
people do it by building a
body of work after many, many decades.
In industry, you kind of get
that trade off where, I mean,
the example I think of
is I worked at threat up
where we know we're a
medium. By the time I left,
we're like a medium
sized company. We're a public.
I have friends who worked at
Meta where When they send an
email to their customer base,
it goes out to fifty
million people. Right? And so, like,
their scope is actually large,
but their inter
interdependencies also
incredible on the amount of
cross functional work they have
to do is very, very high
compared to what I had to do.
So I think you just get
that that trade off,
depending on where you go.
And is that kind of a
challenge when it comes to even hiring
pure academics where they kind of
have that is that one of the
challenges when hiring people
who are more traditionally
academic and transitioning into this
or do you find that people
often quickly transition?
And that's not really
something you are thinking of,
when hiring a people
from traditionally academic background?
I think this goes into
that translation piece.
I can think of three
hiring examples where we took someone
right out of academia
and they started
at a staff level.
That's that's two levels up
from an entry level position in
data science. And
We did that because they
demonstrated their ability to
scope and direct their work
based on their academic experience.
Like, those are those soft
skills that I was saying.
They're really hard to find.
But if you can translate,
you know, that soft scale
into terms that, you know,
your hiring manager can
understand, you can,
you know, you can come
in at a very high level.
If you if you don't come in
at a high level. I think, nonetheless,
you would rapidly rise to
that level because as I said,
it's a rare skill set. And
so if you demonstrate it,
you will be given know,
the additional autonomy
and responsibility, because,
you know, we need people
to do that kind of work.
Thank you both.
Thank you. I see, Jared, you had
asked a question a little bit earlier.
About different educational
backgrounds for data science.
Do you wanna jump in? Hi, Ratin.
Can you guys hear me okay? Yep.
Yeah.
So I guess my question is
just more of a blanket statement,
but given just from these
data science hangouts in general,
people come from such a
wide variety of backgrounds when it
comes to data
scientist positions.
Have you guys found that
there are certain educational
backgrounds or,
I mean, not just
technical skills.
We've talked about soft skills,
but really just focused on,
like, educational backgrounds
that help seem to to
put people in a better position or
seem to be more common than others.
And kind of demonstrate
a road for success.
Okay. You're ready.
Oh, Joe. May maybe, actually,
I'll put something in
your answer. Yeah. Yeah.
So the word self,
reliance comes to mind.
An incredibly diverse background among
the people I work with.
And oftentimes,
they learn their initial data skill
set in service of, you know,
some small business they were
running or some side hustle.
One of my favorite stories,
one of the guys I work with
He was an online gambler and got
really sophisticated
about it. And, you know,
you could see how that
would play into, like,
predictive modeling and a
data science workflow and
I tend to really
see a lot of that where
it's just, you know,
they're they're very, like,
self driven and self engaged
with their with their education
and, you know,
not sure how many on the
call today are our academics. I can
see it in the chatter that there's
a lot, but you know, you know that
big part of the PhD is
self education. You know,
the the course work is not,
like, really the emphasis.
You you have to teach yourself
a lot of skills around
programming or figure out how
to get the resources you need
to learn those new skills and
so that's the background
I see because you're gonna
continuously be
learning on the job.
And so if you can demonstrate
that you have a history of
doing that, I think that's
what sets you up for success.
Are those like that mindset
that, you know, you can,
you can find the resources you
need to to learn the next thing.
Yeah.
I I think also,
I I think one thing that's
kind of challenging about data
science is a field.
I think I would say the
same coming from product is that
it's a more it's a
newer field. Right?
It's a little bit
younger than, like,
software engineering
or or some other,
fields where that those fields
have been a little bit more
defined for longer.
There are programs you can
get in undergrad and engineering
They're like clear
leveling paths, you know,
in these tech companies that have
been established for a long time.
Data science is a little bit
relative to some of these other
areas is still
evolving quite quickly.
The technology is changing very
fast. The methods are changing.
You know, even our
approach, like, AB testing,
I feel like over the last
five years has got has gone through,
like, multiple revolutions.
And so I think that is one
of the challenges for people
coming into it is
figuring out. Okay. Well,
how do I position myself?
What do I spend time, like,
investing skills in? And
I think to this point,
I think I agree with Joe.
I think the ability to
learn new things and figure out,
like, where to learn and grow
next is really important.
Kind of our earlier point
about talking to people and actually
figuring out what's on the
cutting edge of the field and
what might be worth worth it
and what might not be is really
important. Then I think,
like, for academics,
this is actually
not dissimilar.
I think to your PhD research
is that oftentimes those
fields are changing. If
the methods are changing,
you wanna figure out the
best method to answer the question
that you're looking for and you
may need to learn new things.
So so I do wanna call out,
like, I do think that's
something. There's not a
very standard standard path that,
like, if you just do
these things, things will be guaranteed.
And that can make it very
tricky. It also means that, you
know, kind of what
Joe was saying.
Your technical skills
are not enough.
You have to have this
combination of technical skills
and the ability to sort
of navigate organizations
and talk to people and
build relationships because I think
It's the combination of those
two things that makes people,
that actually helps them.
There's yeah.
There's a piece there that
ties a few themes together,
which is like and
we mentioned, like,
informational interviewing
earlier. So, you know,
you learn how to
talk about yourself,
you learn about where
you're interested.
You're also gonna learn what
data science means at that company.
It it's not a
standardized definition.
And I'll say I have
generally found there are two verticals.
There is like a
machine learning AI vertical,
that tends to be
about, like, automating decision making.
This you're automating
small decisions, like,
what should I put in my
cart next? What should I watch next?
And then there's an analytics
vertical. And that tends to be
very thoughtfully
constructing big decisions.
Like, which market
should we pursue next?
You know, which product
feature should we launch next?
And
those are very different.
And, you know,
you may find that you're more
qualified for one or the other.
If you have a ton of machine
learning and predictive
analytics experience, like,
Maybe going down that ML path
is gonna be really promising for you.
If you're really into
like theory building and like
understanding
customer behavior,
analytics vertical can
be a fantastic fit.
Because they're not gonna call
it theory building, but, like,
what are you doing? Like,
you're you're developing
customer narratives trying to
understand customer behavior,
and then you're trying to
change that behavior in, you
know, hopefully positive ways.
And that is very close to
the theory building that you did as
an academic. They're
just, again, translating,
they're not gonna call
it theory and industry.
They're gonna call it like
narrative and context.
And so I saw a great comment
about can I count my years of
PhD and post doc
experience as industry experience? Absolutely.
If you can convince the
hiring manager that those years were
relevant experience,
then they count.
And
In my mind, they count.
And then you should be very
confident in claiming that they
count. I love in the
beginning we were talking about, like,
everybody's first jobs and we
were commenting in the chat,
but also in hangouts before,
we've talked about all the
different kinds of paths that
people take to get to the roles
that they're in now. And I
know not everybody is going
to have a PhD, of course,
to go into to data science.
But I was wondering
if you have other
guidance for people in that
position when maybe the job
posting is is calling for that.
Like, how do you get past that?
Well, maybe I'll I'll start.
I I think, like,
one thing I do wanna kind of
set the tone on is that there
is in in in in my ideal
world when it comes to hiring, you
know, how you would do
things is that you actually, like,
think about the job that
you need to hire for.
You step back and you
really think about what competencies
we're really trying
to hire for. Right?
And then you try to find
candidates who have the ability
or the potential to, like,
meet those competencies.
And those competencies
our, you know,
whatever skills we're looking
for and are somewhat, like,
unrelated to. I saw
a note about, like,
a Stanford PhD or
unrelated to, like,
the school you went to whether
or not you have a PhD, like,
it's very unclear to me if
the PhD is the most efficient way
to get any of these
skills. Right? So, like,
even though both do
and I have it, like,
have a different conversation about
whether or not the pieces
of our things to do.
Right? And so,
so, like, So so I think
that's like kind of the ideal world,
and actually a lot of
the research on sort of,
good hiring practices supports
this general model where, like,
you actually wanna think
about the competencies and you
actually want to hire
for people who have those
competencies no matter
how they got them.
Now the reality of the world
is a little bit different than that,
which is that hiring managers
are often using proxies to try
to get at those things. Right?
They'll use the degree as a
They might use the school that
you went to as a proxy.
And so I just kinda wanna say
that out loud as like the first
kind of the context, which is
the world is not at the ideal
stage, I think that many
of us would wanna be.
And so we have to both, like,
I was once told, you know,
you want to move the world
towards the world that you want
it to be but also recognize
the realities and, like,
address the realities right on.
So I think when there
are certain requirements are on
there, of hard requirements,
I think you do have to
do a little bit more work basically
to try to convince somebody but I
do think that that work is possible.
And again, it kinda
goes back to, I think,
some of the same
themes, which is, like,
if you have a soft intro to
the hiring manager or you talk to
somebody internally. That's
a much easier case, I think,
to to kind of get your name
in the the game and and actually
get that conversation and show
that you have those competencies.
I think another way is,
I've seen some incredible
resumes where they didn't have
sort of the requirements
that maybe were listed.
But they had a
way of basically,
articulating the skills that we were
looking for or even in the
way that they constructed the
resume showed us that they
would be able to communicate
these things very well.
So there are things like that.
But I think in today's
like hiring environment,
which is a little tighter
than it was, you know,
a couple years ago. Like,
one of the the biggest
things I would say is, like,
if you can find a way to
get yourself in front of the the
recruiter or the
hiring manager,
like getting in that door
is probably one of the hardest
steps, I think, in in
today's hiring environment.
But, Joe,
so I think Rachel's initial
question was, like, you know,
if you don't have the
PhD background, like, you know,
how how can you prepare
yourself, for this track? And
Yeah. I think, like, Jen
and I were eluding, like,
getting a PhD is not the
efficient way to gain these
skills. It just happens to
be the way that, we took.
I can tell you my counterpart
in the other half,
in the other other side
of the company has no BHD.
We have the same
title, like, you know,
and his four zero one k is
probably in way better shape.
So, you don't need a PhD.
It's just that,
you know, I wanted to say,
like, if you have one, like,
There are some skills you
inefficiently gained along the
way that now you
can capitalize on.
But if you if you're
not going that route,
I said I heard some
wonderful advice,
from someone who's speaking to
a positive They applied at Apple.
And and the hiring manager
told them, gave some great feedback.
They're like, you're not ready
yet, but here's my advice.
Get a job as an analyst at
a small insurance company.
And and the idea was that
they then had access to some, like,
great, highly relevant data.
And and the idea was just like
while you're in that small
shop, just like knock
their socks off.
You know, like,
use all of the great, like,
open source free resources that
are available in our in
Python and just, like,
build yourself an
amazing portfolio.
And I think this was
amazing advice because actually getting
a hold of relevant data
with signal in it, is hard.
It's not available
at every company,
but like an insurance company
probably does have it. You
know, there's like the
right incentives to get,
that kind of data in place. So
I think, you know,
if you put yourself in
that kind of environment where you
have access to that data,
and then you use it to build
up your skills and demonstrate
your skills, like, know, at
the end of the day, like,
when you're high when you're
when you're interviewing,
you're only gonna get to
tell, like, there were three stories
know, I mean, like,
it's it's actually quite
limited how much of yourself
you're gonna get to show.
So, like, you know, you
think about, like, okay, you know,
you know, you have a
resume with some bullet points of,
like, things you've
accomplished,
then you have two or
three persuasive stories.
If you're really
ambitious, like,
I would recommend starting a blog
so that you can, like, you know,
do more publication, not
publication in the formal
sense, but just
publicizing of you know,
your ability to communicate
and to make, compelling
narrative and
compelling databases.
But That that would be
very ambitious. I rarely see that.
Even among people we hire,
a blog would be, like,
you know, very impressive.
But but just again, you know,
Find the position where you
have access to some interesting
data and and then kinda
just kinda keep building your skills
incrementally from
there and demonstrating
yeah, you don't need the
PhD, to do this kind of work.
It's more of that self
starter, self reliance
that, PhD really requires. So
it becomes like a signal of
that ability, but
it's not the only way.
It's a like we say, it's
a very inefficient way.
It takes five or six years.
So
I see, Mike, you have your
hand raised. You wanna jump in here?
Thanks for that.
It actually wanted to come
back to something that Jen just
said, which I think
is really important.
That it's it's almost like
the CV screening process
is done by people
who don't actually, you know,
they're they're they're using something
to just to go in out
in out. Rather than, you
know, a holistic look at what
actually that person can do. You
know, and so it's like in
that that kind of
screening filtering happens way before
anyone who has a data science
background might even look at your CV.
Sorry. I may be putting words
in your mouth, Jen, but you
know, it it seems to me that
any those kinds of things
are completely arbitrary and
completely unfair because they happen
so far removed from the
hiring manager sometimes.
That I'm wondering
how we redress that?
I think well, I I think
between Joe and I,
we have experiences with, like,
a wide range of companies So
Joe, has worked for a start.
I've sold away to big
companies. And so I I guess,
like, I would say kind of
two things here. One is,
so I'll give two examples of
my job search, which wasn't,
I was actually looking at data
science jobs when I first,
entered the market.
So a couple of things. One,
and I'll I'll I'm
gonna give my example,
but it's an extreme example. So
I kind of knew in December.
I defended my
dissertation in May,
I knew in December that
I wanted to go into industry.
So I just used that
time to informational interview and I
had these hypotheses and I just
talked to a lot of people I
talked to a lot of people.
I ended up because I had never
done a job in tech. I had no
idea what a recruiter was.
I was like, why am I
talking? Who is a recruiter?
What do they do?
So I did over a hundred
informational interviews over
six months, which
again is extreme.
I was, like, writing my
dissertation and had more flexibility.
But the reason I like to tell
this story is that by the time
that I applied to jobs, I
only applied to maybe eight jobs. It
was an extremely targeted
search because I kind of knew
which cultures and teams would
align with what I was looking
for and I had,
some contact at almost every
place that I applied for.
And I think really notably,
the two places where I didn't
have any contact I never heard
back from, I did not make
it past the resume screen.
But all of the places where I
knew a little bit more or had
somebody who was like
a third connection,
I ended up interviewing and and
was able to to get an offer.
So I think, like, that's kind
of one story is really around,
the the the power of
when I tell this story,
I often tell people you'll
either have to do a lot of work
by applying to a
lot of jobs, right,
and do kind of a scattershot
approach and just see who bites,
or you could do a lot of
work upfront and talk to a lot of
people and then do a
more selective search.
So the work is
there either way.
And then the second thing I
would say is I think it really
depends on stage
of company. Right?
So my general
impression, though Joe,
you have way more experience than
me is that I think some of
these things are harder
in larger organizations because
they're just more
systems. Right?
They're getting a lot of
people It's a larger system.
There are more screens,
there are recruiters.
If you go smaller,
and this is kind of the advice
that I was given for for,
product at the time, I was
told that basically it would be
impossible for me to get a
product management job with no
previous experience.
And I think that that
is basically true,
to try to break into product
at a large company would have
basically been almost
impossible, I think, at the
time, But it turns out that
when I go to a smaller company,
they're looking for
very different things.
They're looking for people
who are self starters.
They're also They don't have
as much leverage for hiring
because they can't pay as much
as like the big fan companies
could at the time. And
in that situation, like,
I was able to talk directly
to the hiring manager early on,
etcetera. So I think, like,
the stage of company also will
dictate one how formal
their system is two,
how many layers you have to
go through, and then three,
maybe how accessible it is
to chat chat with people.
But that's my that that's
kind of been my impression
experience. Joe, you might
have a lot more to add. Yeah.
I sorry. I just
saw, you know, your,
ID. It was Smith MK. I didn't
I didn't catch your name. But
Yeah. You mentioned,
like, Mike. Okay.
Apply through the
online portal,
I never do it.
And for the simple
reason that, like,
even with the great credential,
I would routinely
get desk rejected.
It's
it requires networking,
you know, like cold
calls on LinkedIn,
finding people who are second
and third degree contacts and
asking for introductions.
Now I will admit that for
many people, even for me, that is
painful and unwanted activity.
But you can flip that around
and think of it as your
advantage that most people aren't willing
to engage in that kind of,
you know,
door like knocking
on doors essentially,
cold calling to get network
their way in. Now once you
get like that referral.
Now you have a much
more high higher likelihood of actually
getting, like, you know,
the initial part of
the interview started.
But that kind of
networking doesn't end,
at the interview process. Like, that's
big part of the job too.
I mean, once you're
internal so, you know, you
congratulations. You've now been
hired. And, you know,
you're doing work. Well,
you're still gonna need to
figure out how to network
within your company in order
for, you know, your projects to
get greenlit for your projects
to go into production.
That is a skill unto itself too.
And so if I see, you know,
a candidate who are doing
that networking in order to get,
you know, that internal
referral, like,
that's a good signal
to me that, like,
they're gonna be willing to
do of personal networking when
they're inside the
company as well.
You know, submitting to
the portal and, like,
hoping for the best,
it's just such low likelihood
and And once you're inside,
like, finishing your project
and pushing to GitHub and,
like, hoping for the best
is, like, that's not gonna be
enough. Know, you're gonna
need to figure out, like,
who's buying do you need? Get
their feedback in advance.
It's, like, they're
completely parallel processes,
getting into the company,
and then performing once
you're inside the company?
A question that I love
to ask in the hangouts
it's what's a piece of
career advice that you've received
or maybe that you've given
that stands out to you?
Don't know if Jen you
wanna start with this one. Sure.
So actually mine is, Joe.
Joe and I just but,
like, here's the go.
So when I was looking for
my first job, I think Joe, like,
maybe you and Bella had
this heuristic or something, which
is, like, in any job, you
can really only optimize for two
things or at least that's like
a way of thinking about it.
It's like you can only
optimize for two things and everything
else that you get
is like bonus or or,
is great that it
comes with a package.
But once you try to optimize
for more than two things,
the the equation gets, like,
very complicated and the the set
of jobs that you can take
might become too narrow. So an
example is if you care about geography,
pay, mission, culture,
growth. You know,
you can list all these values
that you have and that you want
out of your next job.
It probably is like doable
to get something where you're
mission aligned and get like
a a salary or comp package
that you're happy with.
It's probably possible to get a geography
and a comp package that you want.
It's much harder to try to get
all three in that first job or
in the current
job that you want.
And so I really love this
piece of advice because there are a
couple underlying
principles here.
One is that it means that you need
to get really clear on what you want.
Right? And I think
that some people,
and I fall on this in into
this myself too. It's like,
people approach you with a
job, you get excited about it,
but you actually didn't start
from a place where you were
really grounded in your own
values and what's really
important to you.
So I think that's
great starting point is really
thinking about, like,
what do you want,
and what's most important
to you, miss next step.
And then the second piece that
I really like about this piece
of advice is that
And and there are
many other frameworks.
I've heard people be like,
list your top three priorities
and three extra criteria,
etcetera, etcetera,
But the other thing I like
about this is that it really
puts me at least in a
mindset where careers are not
made by one job. Right? So
just because in that one
job, you're optimizing
maybe you say for,
comp and geography doesn't mean
that your entire career will
not be focused on culture
or mission and things like that.
And,
I think thinking of, you know,
your career and your jobs
as steps along the way that's
building like a larger
career portfolio,
has been really
useful for me. So
I think you need to think about
what are your non like one of
them for me is is culture.
And,
and so but but within that,
I think just having a sense
of prioritization in,
is really useful.
So thanks Joe.
I my I think the like, a
really good piece of advice is
it's easy to think you need
to build a lot of new skills.
In order to get to
make the transition.
And and and I don't
think that's true.
I think you should
focus on polishing
your existing skills.
Rather than building new
ones. Once you're in the job,
then you can build new ones.
But just you have a lot more
skills than you realize.
And if you just polish
those and then, like, refine them,
you know, if you're
doing multiple regression in your
work, great. But I want
you to know multiple regression, like,
all the way down to the
foundations. Before, you know,
you don't need to
start learning, like,
every machine learning
technique in the book.
You know, you can get a
first job just on multiple regression.
But know it really well.
And it's tied to
that, though, is
That doesn't mean that the
job you're qualified for now is
gonna sound exactly like
your PhD dissertation.
I I see a lot of people,
like, overly narrowly define
themselves because that's what
academia promotes you to do.
Is you're like, you get very
narrowly defined in your
identity. And then you look for
a job that sounds like that.
And and I just encourage
you to be open minded.
You know, think more
about, like, you know,
if you if you have a
background in, like, you know,
science or like
diversity and inclusion,
you know, yeah,
there are job titles that
are called like diversity and
inclusion officer, and
that's open to you. Or, and
you could be, a product
manager and just bring that amazingly
unique perspective,
to the role and be an
amazing product manager, or a people
manager who builds a team
where people can thrive.
It it doesn't need to be
your formal job title.
That maps like exactly
to your, you know,
your PhD dissertation.
You know,
you can just bring that
perspective to a traditional
role and excel at it.
Russ, so you have
your hand raised.
Do you wanna add
something here?
Yes. Can you hear me? Yep.
I can. Something different,
but I think extremely
important to hear.
I work as a
professional recruiter.
I'm transitioning
in a data science.
This has nothing to
do with data science.
This is encouragement for all of
you who have been in the situation.
I'm about to
describe my friend.
I've been working with a
friend at the same company for,
I don't know, four or
five years. My friend, you know,
transferred got promoted.
Transfer got promoted and wound up
in a spot that was not good.
I found out two days
ago, my friend was fired.
Okay? So I contacted my
friend and said, Hey,
let me rewrite your resume,
you know, put on qualifications,
stuff like that
because I can do that.
And my friend already
has interviews lined up.
What it means is my friend
did really well in work environments.
So one, two, three, and four,
but number five was a bad
match. That's not a
reflection of my friend.
My friend's gonna keep
going. Moving forward.
If you've had bad
experiences, and we all have,
that's not a reflection on
you. It's just a bad match.
Keep moving forward.
That's how you succeed.
Absolutely.
I have to agree. I
feel like you know,
part of the we've
talked about, like,
the hard skills and the soft
skills and then the other kind
of career skill
overall is that,
we're all just people trying
to figure out work environment
works best for us and what
kind of people we wanna work with
and what kind of
problems. And, you know,
this is something I think
people are not talking about
when you're younger
and in school,
which is you might
like the subject,
but do you like the day to day?
Is there a particular management
style that you like? You know,
what's the mix of meetings and
focus time that works best for you.
And I think thinking about your
career as an explorate as a
self exploration to understand
what works best for you is
ultimately kind of what this is
all about. So one job is just
one job, but it's all
building a body of knowledge.
To figure out what works
best for every single person,
which is gonna be different.
And that's exciting, I think.
Eugene, I I know this
was a bit earlier.
I'm not sure if you're
or you are still on.
But you had a
comment around, like,
this idea of being
obsessed with correctness
And when businesses
don't necessarily,
prioritize on that, do
you wanna jump in here?
Sure.
I've had
I have a lot of academic
training and I've never been
much of an academic,
person I feel very
pragmatically driven. It was
like, Twenty percent of the
work was getting new results,
but eighty percent was always
saying how wrong they might be
and reporting on the
different ways to do.
Things that might end up wrong
or where your data came from.
And I I never enjoyed
that part of it.
But the people that
I've worked with,
the more academic they are and
one of the close people I work
closest with right
now is an MD PhD.
And it never feels like some
of the tasks that we work on
together are done enough
or correct enough or
accurate enough
and it creates this.
I can never really tell the
people who depend on our deliverables
how done he feels. You
know, or a a former
coworker, you know,
we were we were fine
tuning financial marketing models together.
And he would say, but this is
wrong. This is not the way to
do it. And I would
constantly have to say
it does the data validate that
there is lift or that we're
getting incremental, you know,
lift or that the modeling
is actually producing
you know, gains.
You know, wouldn't it work
if you put this in, you know,
does the data show
that this might work?
And he wouldn't say yes,
but this is not the right
way to do it. So it was this
I felt like when working with
a lot of academics, they they
they wanted so much more completeness
and accuracy,
you know, and and certainty
about about their approach to be,
validated by research,
validated by other, you know,
people who know the exact
way to do small statistics, large
statistics, mean, I think one
of the funniest things, you
know, you guys can riff on
this as long as you want.
But when you get into big data,
every single thing you
measure is statistically significant.
Every single one.
So what do you do
when every possible number, you know,
has error bars this tiny.
And and it's really hard to
get people past, you know, that
that frame of mind from what my
experience is with academics in in business.
Okay. I think that that
actually points out a good transition,
point of, like,
What are the standards
you're working to? You know,
if you are doing basic research
and you're trying to build knowledge,
then having this, like,
exclusive body of rigorous
findings is the goal.
That's not the goal
at most businesses.
You know, again, you know,
if you're doing, like,
medical research, then, you
know, that's that's different. Like,
you actually that there is
more of scientific goal in there.
But, oftentimes, you
know, you think of, like,
businesses are often it's more
of like an investment strategy.
And so now it's
not about, like,
building an exclusive
body of knowledge,
it's about really
optimal stopping.
How long should we explore
for so that we can you know,
exploit that knowledge,
for maximum gain.
And that's a different,
a different standard.
It's not a lower standard.
It's it's a different goal,
and then that that goal
brings within a different standard.
So that's a change
of mindset that
you should be prepared to make.
You know, like,
it's not gonna serve you well
to bring over like academic standards
to an environment where
those won't serve you.
So yeah,
most business settings
are gonna be more about
optimization than
they are about,
you know, building
scientific knowledge.
Although there will
be some overlap.
But yeah, it's a different
standard as as my, answer.
Yeah. And, Eugene,
your question kinda reminds me of
a a conversation I had very
early on when I first
got into industry,
which was that you
know, in in academia,
what we care about is, if
if you get a result, like,
let's say you run an experiment
and you know, your null result
is like nothing or your,
you know, the the kind of
the worst case is basically nothing
changes. Right? Like,
it's like in academia,
that's like the worst case.
Now you don't have anything
that you can report on.
But if you get an unexpected
result either way,
it's more positive than you
thought or it's more negative
than you thought.
Now you have an interesting
result and you can talk about
it and try to figure out
causality and all these things.
In business, kind
of to Joe's point,
If academia is about building
knowledge in business,
I say a lot of the times it's
just about reducing risk.
So a lot of the time,
the standard of decision
making is we don't want,
actually a good
result would be, like,
that nothing changes
or it's positive.
And the bad result is if
it makes the the outcomes that we
care about worse. Right?
And so that's that to me
is such a fundamental change in
how you look at it because
if you're trying to be like, oh,
should we roll out this change
in our business? Really,
what a lot of leaders care
about is they just wanna make
sure that it doesn't
make things worse. Right?
And so either if it's the
same or better, then that's great.
But that same result in
academia, if it's the same,
is seen as like a not
very valuable result.
And and I think that that
shift is quite fundamental and And
it's understandable.
I think that many
people struggle with that shift
because, you know,
you're in any organization with
its own values set and things
like that. You do absorb
that way of thinking,
and sometimes it needs to
be called out extremely explicitly
to help people understand how
they were thinking before.
Because before in academia,
everybody thought this way,
there was no need to call
it out at all. You know,
and so sometimes it's hard
to identify when you're actually
in a different kinda
actual environment.
I know this time goes
by so quickly. So one
other
question I I'd love for us to get
to is I I know a lot of us
are in a position where
we're hoping to advance our career,
maybe get the next promotion
and was wondering what advice
you may have for some of us
who are in that position right now.
You know, we talked earlier
about, like, networking.
And I think that, you know,
promotion
is often has a,
has a social component.
It's not to say it's popularity
contest. It is to say, like,
you need to be well
aligned with, you know,
your lead your managers
and leaders about, like,
what skills,
what demonstrations are going to
warrant, that promotion. And so
you know,
if you're if you're
seeking promotion within your company,
like, my advice would be like,
start that as an
explicit conversation.
You know, with your
manager about, like,
what are the skills
that, you know,
you need to see demonstrated,
what are the, you know,
accomplishments that, you know,
you need to see so that
it's not like a mystery that arrives
at the end of the year,
but it's like an explicit, conversation.
And then, you know,
you don't have to you don't
have to stop there. Like, you
know, look around at who
else is getting promoted, you know,
within your org and, like,
reading between the lines of
like, okay. Well,
what have they accomplished
that distinguished them from,
you know, the rest of
their their peers? And,
I think that, you know,
getting aligned on
expectations, but also, like,
just being a lot of this
just keeps coming back to like being
very resourceful and self driven
about, like, finding a path
to,
to your goals. And,
you know, if you're
willing to do that,
I think you have a
lot more opportunity,
to, to attain promotion.
Yeah. I think,
yeah, we we keep coming back to
the same themes over and over, right,
which is like you need to find
a way to carve your own path to
some extent when it's not
that clear and and talking to
people. I think for promotion,
one story kind of
comes to mind of,
kind of earlier when I had
first come to industry,
which is I was a very process
oriented person You know,
I really believe that if
you set up good processes,
you basically bias all
of your outcomes towards,
everything is kind of I
looked at things like very
probabilistically So it's like I'll
set up a good process.
That means that, you know,
the probability that I get
a better outcome is sort of
determined, in terms of how
you make those decisions.
And so I used to I spent
my first six months on the job
just talking all about these
new processes I had implemented
and how great they were.
And I have I got feedback
was kind of like we're an outcomes
driven organization, Jen. Like, all
this talk of process, not,
like, it's not doing it for
us. And I I remember my first
reaction was just sort of
like frustration. I was like,
come on, but process
is so important.
But I think it kinda goes
to this advice, which is that,
different organizations will
value different things and,
every organization is is its
own little fiefdom with its own
set of values. So you
wanna spend time getting that feedback,
figuring out what actually
matters and how it talked about
and how it's framed,
but I ended up taking a lot
of the same things that I used to
talk about from a process
perspective, and I just kind of
framed it and was able to show
how it led to pros to outcome,
and I would really focus
on talking about the outcomes.
And it was a total turnaround
in terms of how people
perceived the contributions that I
made even though it was
the same kind of work.
Right? So I think That's
one thing is, like,
figure out what
matters to the org.
And then the second thing
I would say about promotion is
that increasingly, I think
at some levels, you know,
depending on your track,
the promotions end up being like similar
work but also at a certain point,
there's some promotions that lead
to jobs that have like
different it's like a
different job. Right?
Like,
I kind of at some point was an
IC and went to a manager and it
was ended up being a
very different job.
And so one last thing I I kind
of wanted to add to add here is
that increasingly now I am kind
of, I increasingly, I'm I'm
trying to really step
back and be like,
is this a promotion
I actually want?
And is this kind of promotion
at this company the kind of
promotion that I want?
Because there there are times in
my career so far where the
work that I've loved to do
the most was actually when I was
kind of in a different role
and had slightly different
responsibilities.
And so Obviously, now
with a bit of, like,
hindsight and reflection,
I can think about what are
the elements that I really loved,
but this goes back to our
earlier point about how I think
ultimately all of this is
really about trying to figure
out what's the
right fit for you.
And sometimes that's correlated
with role and title and
sometimes that's not.
And sometimes it's correlated with
the role and title at your
company, but may not be
correlated somewhere else.
So just kind of the
broader, just wanted to mention that.
I'll tag on one more thing
I just thought of, which was,
so Intuit, they have this,
principles community.
So they get all of
the principal level,
like engineers and data
scientists together and, you
know, we like to talk. And
One thing that came out of
that meeting recently that was
really interesting was just
like this theme of, like,
willingness to
take informed risk.
You know,
like
and I think this is actually,
like, in hindsight, like,
a really important theme
of, like, you know, if
promotion is not
assured. You know, like,
you're you're probably gonna have
to take some informed risks.
And maybe that means
like investing your time and
learning a new modeling
technique, or a new, you know,
you know, I I don't know
what that's gonna be for you.
But That means, like, investing
time and, you know, and, like,
you're you're taking
your risk. Like, maybe,
maybe it won't work out.
You're not gonna get, you know,
promoted on that project.
But it was something that
came out of a lot of people
independently in
that room was, like,
it that willingness
to take informed risk.
And Maybe there were a lot
of people who weren't in the room
because their informed risks, like,
didn't work out. But, it
I I I think that that
willingness, to to, like,
to to take a bet on yourself,
and, like, you know,
pursue something that not
everyone else is doing,
can be really important
if you're seeking promotion.
Yeah. Thank you so much.
I I think that that question
had been top of mind for me
lately because I was talking
to somebody who was saying they,
like, save, like,
their whole work week.
They save forty hours
a week by doing, like,
parameterized quarto documents.
And they were advocating for
a promotion for themselves.
And I was thinking, wow,
that's amazing. You just
made all this new time
for yourself. Like,
you you could possibly use
that in getting this promotion.
And just like kind of flipping
that that mindset a little bit.
Yeah. Well Yeah. I mean,
that's a great example.
That wasn't something that was
defined for them. Yeah. Like,
no one was saying, oh, this is
how you should do your job. Like,
they took a totally new
approach to how to accomplish
their job and save an
enormous amount of time.
And I think those kind of
examples are like great ways to
demonstrate that you have the,
like,
scoping and autonomy abilities
that warrant the next level.
Absolutely. Well,
I feel like we could all
keep talking about this stuff for
ever, and this hour went
by really, really quickly.
But thank you so much,
Jen, and and Joe,
for joining and sharing
your experience with us all.
This has been great.
Yeah. Yeah. Thank you. Well,
the questions have
been so thoughtful.
I've just been I I've been
learning a lot from the questions.
I'm like, oh, this
is great questions.
It is really fun to to
read through the chat.
So if anybody wants
to save the chat,
there's those little three
dots on the bottom there.
And you can just
click save chat too.
But Jen and Joe, if people
want to get connected with you as
LinkedIn in the best place,
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Awesome. Well,
thank you all so much.
Have a great rest of
the day. Thank you.